[Music]
hello everybody yes it's me again
prepare for more bugs I'm kind of
excited to be here because we finally
reached a point where with Houdini I can
talk about actual api's because they're
starting to land and that's kind of
really exciting but after any talk I
kinda have to start with what Houdini is
because on my Twitter I often see this
little confusion because it turns out
there's a software called Houdini there
is apparently a magician that was called
Houdini so I kind of want to clear up
what Houdini really is about so every
browser has more or less four major
stages in their rendering pipeline
it starts with styles where the browser
collects all the style Xi's are in the
document and then figures out which
elements is affected by which of these
styles and now that we know the width
the height and you know if it's flexbox
or great which style is on which element
we can do layout we can basically
calculate how big an element is and like
align them on the page and get boxes on
the page they're so empty and
transparent because in the next stage we
can take that layout page and paint it
just draw it and we can draw it on the
page sometimes elements get on their own
piece of paper which is called a layer
and once we're done painting respecting
things like background color and the
text color and the border color we can
give all of that all these pieces of
paper to the compositor and kind of put
them together into the page that you
will see on your screen and if something
was on its own layer we can move the
pieces of paper around and that's how
animations are made I mean it's
obviously kind of a shortcut but you can
kind of see where I'm coming from so
bringing it back to the question what
really is Houdini
well Houdini is a standards effort in
the CSS working group in the w3c to
expose hooks into these major stages of
the layout phase to developer to you so
you have more control not only over the
visuals but to write by the polyfills
and have more control over how your page
just appears to the user it is hard
because these four stages are different
in every
brother sometimes they're even parallel
or not even you know that clearly
separated but we're trying to working
with all the browsers to make sure
everybody can implement these api's
Houdini can be super intimidating at
first because under the Houdini umbrella
that's a lot of api's and you don't
really immediately know what to do with
what but they actually kind of form a
hierarchy so you have four high level
api's four major api's that basically
represent those four major stages of the
rendering pipeline and then you have a
couple of lower-level api's that build
the underpinning the basis for Houdini
and that make these higher level api is
possible in the first place
and specifically worklets are really
interesting worklets are kind of the
Swiss Army knife with in Houdini for
performance and so I want to make sure I
take a second to explain these because
we're going to use them for the rest of
the talk and more importantly I want to
distinguish them from workers because
lots of people confuse these two and I
can blame them because they sound very
similar and in fact they actually have a
lot of overlap but there is a couple of
very important differences that I want
to explain to you and for that we have
to talk about the event loop this is an
event loop and if you don't know much
about the event loop that's absolutely
fine everything that you need to know I
will explain to you today but if you
want to know more I really recommend
watching
Jake's talk about the event loop which
you can probably find on youtube if you
just type in his name and event loop and
actually I'm using a lot of his visuals
in this talk so this is an event loop
it's loop and it processes events and
it's called an event loop whenever an
event happens the JavaScript engine
checks if there's a handler for this
events in your code base and then takes
the code for that handler and queues it
up and every turn the event loop takes
something out of the queue and runs it
and then in the next turn it takes the
next thing out of the queue and runs it
and that's obviously super simplified
and there's much more nuance to this
entire thing but that's kind of how an
event loop works and in this world a
worker would look like this it's a
completely separate event loop it's an
isolated scope it has its own handlers
its own events and they have nothing
to do with it with each other they might
be able to put a task into the other
loops queue with postmessage but that's
pretty much it and there is considerable
cost to spinning up and maintaining an
event loop and that's why you can't just
spin up a thousand workers and call it a
day
because that's actually quite costly
worklets are different they're also
isolated javascript code and you know
with their own scope but work glue
worklets don't have an event loop
instead they kind of attach to already
existing event loops and that makes them
a lot cheaper to create and maintain and
you can even attach multiple worklets to
an already existing event loop and
because most worklets are specified to
be stateless we can even migrate them in
the middle of the lifetime so if it
makes more sense for your code to run in
sync with another event loop we can just
take it off and take it to the next
event loop where it makes more sense so
this will come in really handy later on
but that's basically the big difference
between those two and now that we have
worklets in our back pocket we can
finally talk about the very first
Houdini api which is for the paintwork
lights so as i said another ago three is
in order by the way more like an order
of veil ability if that makes sense but
for the paid worklets the api is called
the CSS paint api and as I said all
elements have to be painted sooner or
later to be able to appear on screen and
so far you have been able to use CSS to
customize how your elements appear
on-screen but only with those ways that
CSS exposes so for example if you want
to do rounded corners you can reduce
border radius and you get this and it's
kind of great but it also turns out that
there's different ways to make a box
seem like it has rounded corners and if
you want to use any of these other ways
you kind of screwed nowadays because
what do you do so for example there is a
so called skwerkel which mathematically
speaking is closer to a circle and a
square and it doesn't change curvature
abruptly at all so it has a kind of
different aesthetic look which is could
be kind of nice so if you wanted to have
this thing on the web today what do you
do you can maybe do an S
background image which is not really a
border you could maybe use some a canvas
or nine slice image I don't know
but with Houdini you can actually teach
CSS how to draw the exact look that you
want to have on your page so how does
this work
step one with all worklets is that you
have to load a javascript file into the
worklet that the browser gives to you so
in this case we have the CSS namespace
and all the worklets that Houdini brings
to the browser are going to be in the
CSS namespace sooner or later so in this
case it's called paint worklets and
every worklet has an Add module call
with which you can load a javascript
file into that worklet let's take a look
inside this file in that file we want to
teach CSS how to paint something new
with JavaScript but first it needs a
name so there is a register paint
function and it takes a class and now we
want to basically associate a name with
that class and every paint class and
this can amusing my paint we need to
define a paint call and this paint call
gets a context which is almost identical
to the canvas contact that you're
hopefully familiar with a geometry
object which tells you how much width
and height the element has that you're
supposed to paint and a properties
object which allows you to read the
styles of the object at your painting so
like background color text color font
size all these things are in there for
you to read and now what I'm doing here
is basically I'm setting my full style
to hot pink and just draw the biggest
possible circle in the middle of the
elements not very useful but in the way
useful for me to show you what is
actually going on so now that we have to
find how to draw this appearance how do
we tell the browser to actually use this
new appearance so we do certain CSS so
in this case I'm just setting a new
style and you can use paint worklets
everywhere that CSS expects an image so
in this case I'm setting the background
image not you in your L but to attain
and use the name that I use and register
paint in here so here I use paint my
paint and this is actually if it works
this is not good I told you prepare for
my bugs no the entire laptop froze No
okay maybe maybe it's coming back to
life I'm gonna try something I achieved
something today all right as I was
saying yeah we load that file we had
that we had this one we draw a circle in
the middle and I want to do the big
reveal where we use the paint function
for the background image instead of just
a normal SVG image I'm gonna press the
button we have a pink circle I'm so
happy
by the way everyone thank you so much
for the kind messages on Twitter and
your support in the room it could have
been so much worse thank you very much
what I'm doing here is as I said I set
the background image on a text area so
this is a text area where I'm animating
within Heights don't do this at home
kids never animate within Heights but
you can see the circle is pink and in
the middle so you might be asking what
is the advantage of using Houdini's
paint API what this talk is about over
using a normal canvas so there's a
couple of things I want to talk about
the first one is auto repaint meaning
that the browser can figure out when it
actually needs to run your code to do
these painting operations and want to
talk about this more a little bit later
in the talk it is auto sized if you've
ever worked with the HTML canvas you
know that the number of pixels on an
HTML canvas is completely independent
from the number of pics of the canvas
has on the screen which is super painful
to work with and in this case you don't
have to worry about it because it is
automatically set to the correct size it
is off main thread meaning the code that
you write to do the paint operation
doesn't run on the main thread and
that's a lie currently in chrome we do
run it on the main thread but as I said
to worklets can be migrated so the
second we have the infrastructure in
place to run this kind of code somewhere
else it will just happen and that means
you don't use any of your main thread
budget making sure your page
buttery smooth no Dom overhead and this
one is actually very underrated often I
see effects on the web that use a couple
of Dom elements or any kind of assembly
of different styles to achieve a certain
visual effect with this you're yet just
using a virtual canvas so not even one
Dom element to achieve this effect and
that can really add up on low-end phones
so for example this is one of the no no
but for me this just means I'm gonna
skip that slide so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go out of full screen and
moving this to a different slide they're
going to back into full screen and we're
going to go so this one Wow
all right my point that I was trying to
make was that we found on low-end
devices implementing these kind of
effects like this wonderful effect that
unna implemented is actually more
efficient in custard and the paint
worklet than using a million Dom
elements so that's why this is actually
a performance primitive to make your app
run buttery smooth even on the low-end
devices this is another fact that you
know wrote that I think is really nice
and this is kind of point a nice example
to show how the browser can decide when
to paint and when not to paint so in the
paint class you can declare your
dependencies you can say this these are
the CSS properties that I rely on and so
the browser knows only when any of these
properties change will the code have to
run otherwise it won't and so in this
case you have a couple of custom
properties saying I want to have this
number of stars and these you and this
different size is kind of thing and then
in theater I just wiki frame animation
on the U and you end up with this effect
and it's actually efficient in the sense
it doesn't run just
raph every frame but only repaints when
the animation actually tells you it is
necessary this is another fact a simple
clock that many people you know might
write with SVG or with a canvas some
people would again probably bend over
backwards and try to make this happen
with a Dom and just a couple of Dom
elements but if you look closely you can
see that the hand actually has a trail
and that suddenly makes it a lot harder
to do with SVG orbit the Dom and maybe
canvas would be more appropriate the
nice thing here is that you can have
this module o'clock CSS Houdini module
and configured with just a couple of
custom properties so you can animate the
background color or the color of the
hands the thickness of the hands the
thickness of the circle at the end or
the length you can show or not show the
individual stops on the clock you could
do all of these things at once but it
gets like really stressful to look at so
I would I wouldn't do that but it's just
a clock and once again this this trail
is just a CSS transition to the browser
knows while the transition is going on I
need to repaint this every frame but the
second the trail is done it stops
repainting so a really easy performance
wind so far we've been using CSS paint
for background images and we have gotten
pretty far I think if you still remember
what I was talking about a couple of
hours ago it feels like but you can use
it anywhere with CSS expection image so
for example you could also use it for a
mask image or a border image so in the
land of Porter image you could make this
kind of organic look where the border
looks kind of hand-drawn and if you want
that kind of look
CSS paint makes it really easy to
achieve that effect this is probably
very important progressive enhancements
and you can detect support for paint
rotate in both JavaScript and in CSS one
note about the absent acts for at
supports it detects support for paint
worklet not for one specific paint
workers so even if the name like in this
case something doesn't actually exist as
a painter oklet it will still get
evaluated which is kind of handy for
this talk I want to introduce the three
pick stability index which is supposed
to be a little notion of how stable and
ape an API is based on the story of the
three pigs and the wolf who tries to
blow their house down so in this case in
the
CSS paint API the spec is a candidate
recommendation which is basically w3c
speak for its stable it's shipped to
stable and Chrome Safari announced that
they have it in development right now
and with that I will call it brick
stability at the bottom by the way is
supposed to be a brick emoji but the
brick emoji just got standardized in
June of this year so none of the funds
have it yet but luckily it still kind of
looks like a brick if you want to know
more about this API I'm gonna
shamelessly self block the article that
I wrote which you can find here and if
you have any questions hit me up anytime
and with that out the way we finally
have talked about the first Houdini API
and I'm gonna can go on to the next one
and see if the browser will handle this
I just realized I should I risk hiding
the URL bar I will do it good the next
one compositing as I said the compositor
main job is to do animations with the
papers that move around so as such the
animation is called the animation
worklet API so let's talk about that a
bit if you currently think about
animations on the web you have three
choices it's more like two-and-a-half
choices you have CSS transitions which
allow you to transition is CSS property
from the current value to a new value
you have CSS keyframe animations which
are a declarative timeline API which is
more powerful and can do some kind of
looping and you have a web animations
API which is the imperative version that
allows you to do like nested timelines
and all kinds sorts of things but the
problem is that it's really badly
supported it's behind the flag in Safari
Chrome has an implementation but it's
missing a lot of features each doesn't
have it at all so it really isn't
usually a good choice but even if it was
there are often scenarios where what web
animations API offers is not enough and
this is where animation droplet API
would come in so what you see here is a
normal web animations API animation it
would usually web animations API is
thought about in the dot animate call
this is the same thing just a little bit
more elaborate it's also part of the API
and a rockered animation is actually
very very similar so for example I would
just use a work with animate
of an animation and because we are
associating this animation with the
worklets we need to once again provide a
worklet name other than that it stays
the same so we have a keyframe effect
that we target an element with and we
have two keyframes that we want to use
within two seconds then now we have an
animation worklet on the CSS namespace
and can call add module and now within
our animation file we can use javascript
we have an animate callback where we get
the current time and the effect of the
animation and now it's our job to set
the local time of the effect depending
on the current time if we do it like
this where we don't think about it it's
literally a pass through and it will
behave just like a normal web animation
API but this is JavaScript so you can
basically implement arbitrarily complex
time mappings now what does this
actually mean I'm not going to go into
all the details of this API but just
going to give you a little taste of it
so if you want to know more I'm gonna
shamelessly self like another article I
wrote which you can find here and and
again read it and give me a feedback I
would very much welcome that but how do
what do you use animation rocket for so
for example and I think a year ago or
two years ago Safari proposed the spring
timing function and it's employed in
Safari I don't think any other browser
has employed it so far but what do you
do if you want to use it or what do you
do if you have any other timing function
it doesn't exist and you want to use it
this is where animation worked it would
come in handy so in this case we can for
example write it bounce any matter
because if you think about it if you
animate an element from A to B you can
either just move it from A to B but you
could also move from A to B and a little
bit back and a little bit less back and
it will look kind of like a bounce and
that's exactly what I gonna do so we
have a constructor where we take some
options in this case there's going to be
an option for for example for bounciness
which makes sense how bouncy is it
supposed to look and in the animate call
we are going to use this bounce function
to depending on the bounciness and the
current time we're gonna determine where
in between these two key frames will
want to end up so the bounce function i
used i implement with some really dodgy
and hand wavy physics but in the end you
can just think about it like
implementing this kind of graph between
two key frames so if we do that and we
run that you can see that it's now
actually a bounce and keep in mind that
this is literally just two key frames
and we're just bending
time so to speak and this animation
because it's a worklet runs off the main
thread it actually runs on the
compositor thread meaning that even if
the main thread is super busy it will
make sure that this animation runs
exactly at the devices framerate frame
perfect and make sure that your
animations look really really smooth so
so far we have done this we have an
animation but if you look at this I
explicitly wrote out document time and
even though it's an optional argument
the point is that with animation
worklets you could get time from
somewhere else not just actual time you
could for example think of something
like a scroll timeline or you could even
conceive us on like an input timeline we
are talking about info China but I have
nothing to show here but I can show you
scroll timeline so here you see a pacman
that I've linked to a scroller at the
bottom so do you see it I became
basically scroll the scroller at the
bottom and the animation will jump to
the position where I am within the
scroller and so it kinda gives this it
gives you an animation scrubber and this
is I mean it's kind of fun but not that
useful but you can see conceive of more
useful user default scroll linked
effects where I have three independent
animation the follow button my name and
my avatar are all scrolling effects that
can assume their position within the
animation depending on how far I scroll
the parallax effect would be another
very popular choice to do to use with
this and it's much easier to implement
that it currently is on the web now in
combination with CSS scripts CSS scroll
snap points that we just implement in
chrome you can now have a lot of synergy
here where you have really smooth
transitions between different sections
of your app and you see have like an
indicator and top and the images kind of
zoom into view and now the for me the
really interesting thing is that
animation rocket is the same thing as
the paint work that was for rounded
corners if you don't like how scrolls
net points work animation work at its
low level enough to allow you to
implement your own version so it really
future proofs the web for whatever
people will come up with in the future
let's talk about the three Pixability
index for this API which we have gone
through many many iterations
animation Brooklyn but always in
collaboration with Apple with Microsoft
and with Mozilla and we are now at a
point we feel fairly confident that all
the browsers are at least on board on a
conceptual level with what we come up
with so all in all I would give this a
would stability as I said we feel pretty
confident about it but now it's really
time for us to see what you feel about
it so it is in canary you can play with
it now and we're going to an origin
trial in chrome 71 so if you want to
test out in production and we would love
it if you do please sign up here and as
I said the article will should give you
all the info that you need to get
started and if not please contact me I'm
very eager to help out so that we can
get some real data on the benefits of
animation droplets I have I don't know
how many time I have left at this point
I'm just going to go for it because I
can talk a little bit about layout API
so the layer API I'm gonna start with
the three big stability index because
it's complete straw-like we literally
refactor this API two weeks ago a TPAC
so there is like a half-finished
implementation in canary and you should
play with it but don't expect the code
to still run next week um but there's so
much potential in this edit I really
want to give you like a little insight
into this so with the custom layout API
or the layout worklets you can basically
define your own display values so I'm
just going to have the main element a
couple of divs in there and that's it
everything all the other magic will
happen in the worklets so now we have a
layout brooklet on the CSS namespace I'm
going to add the module and in there we
have a layout callback I'm not gonna
explain all the parameters because hey I
don't understand them all and the layout
is pretty complex but I'm gonna keep
this one simple so we can get a feel for
it so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
going to loop over all the children all
my child nodes that are on my custom
element my custom layout elements I'm
gonna lay them out in empty space
basically asking how big would you be if
you had no constraints and then I'm just
gonna give them a random offset
basically giving them a random position
within the rectangle that I occupy and
then I return this list of the browser
saying I did my layout now please go
forth and paint me and that's exactly
what the browser will do so if you look
at this you can see a couple of
rectangles and
every couple seconds I add or remove a
rectangle to force a relay out and they
get a truly random position which is
also truly useless but you can see that
this is actual delay out face of the
browser this runs during the layout face
of the browser something that was
completely closed off to developers so
far it's time to give a look more for
useful example I also implemented a
masonry layout so here I'm just loading
random images from unsplash with
different aspect ratios and the masonry
algorithm if you will takes care of
assembling these in three columns and
the number of columns is once again just
the custom properties which I can
increase and what kind of scale up and
give you this really nice masonry look
which so far you would always have to do
with position:absolute magic and main
thread JavaScript and this is just
actual layout which I think is really
exciting if you're into in the code
because I don't have an article for
anything for layered work like yet
mostly because by the time I would be
done with an article it would be out of
date again please go to this repository
that I maintain where I have samples for
all the workers I talked about today and
you can fork them and play around with
them or I would be so happy if you
contributed to them I kind of want to
build a collection of off-the-shelf
Houdini elements with popular effects
which I think have really useful if you
want to keep up with the development of
Houdini I made is Houdini ready yet calm
where you can see all the browsers which
Houdini API may support which ones are
in development which ones they at least
want to implement in time there is links
to the articles to demos to the specs
every hopefully I can make this like the
one-stop shop that you need to keep up
with Houdini and I can't believe that I
made it to my last slide
[Applause]
[Music]